- Hey everybody,
my name is Milecia McGregor.
And today I'll be talking to you
about making VR more interesting
with JavaScript and Brain.js.
So, I'm a developer advocate at Conducto
where we make CI/CD tools
and if you want
you can follow me on Twitter @FlippedCoding.
So to get started,
I'll give you a background on VR,
then we'll actually make a small VR app.
Then we'll go over
a little bit of background on machine learning,
mainly neural networks.
And then we'll actually add the machine learning code
to the VR app.
Then we'll go over a few other considerations
when you're working with a VR application.
And then we'll just go through some key takeaways.
So just to get started with a little background on VR,
it's a relatively new area of tech,
just because the hardware
has been more recently created,
but the applications for virtual reality
span across all kinds of industries
from training medical students,
to video games,
to different forms of entertainment.
And so this leads to a different career path
that developers can take.
It doesn't matter if you know,
C, C# or JavaScript,
you can find a place for you in VR.
And then as this hardware starts to improve,
you'll notice that virtual reality
is gaining more momentum
as something that companies are looking to invest in.
So, that's where we
get a lot of the different career opportunities,
but this is the fun part.
So we're gonna go through a live demo
of how to make a VR app.
Okay, so one thing that might be surprising
is that you just start with an HTML file.
This is the A-Frame library.
So all you have to do is,
import the code here,
just in a script file like anything else.
And we also import another package
that gives us access to some pre-made environments,
because when you are working with the VR application
you need different assets
in the world that you create.
And those take a lot of time
and different skillsets.
So when you can take advantage
of a pre-made package,
it's okay to do that.
And then we have a few other JavaScript files
that we'll talk about a little bit later.
But just so you know
how a VR application works,
its just a web application,
but with different kinds of tags.
So you'll see we're just inside the body,
but A-Frame uses these different A-tags.
So when you're working on a VR application,
you'll have a scene.
And basically what this is,
is everything that is in your VR world.
But the first thing you do in a scene,
is import all of the assets that you wanna use.
So in this case,
we have a few JPEGs
that we're going to make into textures
for the different objects
we put in the world.
And I did have music for this game,
but once I realized this talk was gonna be recorded,
I don't think you wanna hear that
playing over and over again.
But if you want it to include music,
you just use the audio tag
like you would in any other JavaScript project.
So we have our assets,
that means it's time to start putting objects
into the VR world.
And the first thing we're gonna put in those just blocks,
just a regular box.
And what makes this one kind of special,
is that if you see here
the source is actually the same
as this wooden texture asset.
That means that this block
is gonna look like a piece of wood.
And this attribute
is the height of the object.
So in A-Frame you can set different attributes
on these A-Tags
and they determine how the shape is built
inside of the world.
So in this case,
our box is gonna have,
a height of three meters
because A-Frame measures everything in meters.
And then it's rotated a little bit
around the Y and the Z-axis,
just to show you something different in the world.
And here you'll see the position.
This one is really important
because this is exactly where
the object is going to be in the world.
So this means that
it's gonna be 37 meters in the X direction,
it's gonna be one meter off of the ground
and then it's gonna be 37 meters
in the Z direction behind us.
So that's how the positioning works with A-Frame.
And another attribute
is this animation position,
basically what this does,
it lets you customize animations on objects.
So what we're doing here
is taking the property that we want
to animate for this block,
and we're say we want to change the Y position
to 2.2 meters every two seconds.
So that means this block
will just float up and down
between one meter and 2.2 meters.
And then the last thing here for attributes,
is this custom attribute.
So this is one that we'll talk about
as soon as we're done in this file.
And if you'll notice
there are some just primitive shapes here.
So you can use boxes, spheres, cylinders,
they're all built into A-Frame.
But down here we have something just a little bit different,
this is a plane
and all that is is, a plane,
it's like having a sheet of paper
that you can make magically float in your world.
And what we've done with this plane,
is just write down a few of the things
that we want the user to find in the game
that we're making.
And to do that,
we use the base A-Frame tag,
which is
and you can set which kind of primitive shape
it should be with an attribute.
So in this case,
we just wanna text
because it's a list of items
that the player needs to find in the game.
And it's right at the beginning
where they can see it,
so they don't need to walk around to find it.
Then down here,
we get to another entity,
which has the environment.
And that is what really makes the layout for your world.
So that library that we imported in the beginning,
it's responsible for building a world
based on these different attributes,
which you'll get to see in a few seconds.
But the last thing that I wanna show you
before we get into the game,
is probably the most important part of a VR application,
and that's the camera.
So where you position your camera
changes the entire game play for a user.
And that could be,
you put the camera behind them
so that they can see themselves walk around,
you can make it into first person view
so that it looks like you're just looking around
in the game
or you can do any kind of camera positioning
that makes sense for what you're making.
But what we have here
is just a camera
that's slightly behind the user.
So it looks like a first person view
and we've added just a little ring to the center
of the camera,
so that as the user moves around
they can determine what they're looking at.
So now let's just go ahead
and run this app.
So it should be running.
It takes a little while for A-Frame to load sometimes,
but it's a really good library
to get started with.
Now, you see,
this is the environment
that we imported from that library.
And we have our list of things,
we can look around,
walk around and maybe find something
I'm not sure exactly where it is, right...
Oh, I think we found some...
Hey, so we found this object
and when you click on it,
that sends it back to the starting position
because you're collecting this.
So the way that that works
is in this found item,
this is that custom attribute
that we briefly mentioned earlier.
And whenever you want to make a specific action
for a VR object,
this is how you do it in A-Frame.
So whenever you click on one of the objects
you're looking for in the game,
it goes to a specific position
back at the starting point,
and that's it.
So back to the presentation,
now that you have seen the VR app,
we'll talk a little bit about machine learning.
So neural networks are a form of machine learning algorithm
and they're just used to make predictions.
So a neural network is made of layers of notes,
because it's supposed to try to represent
what the brain is like.
And basically you give it a set of inputs,
you assign some weighted values to it
to highlight the importance of each input.
And then the neural network
goes and makes different connections and assumptions
and gives you an output.
So you've probably heard of deep learning before
and all this is,
is just a neural network
with multiple nodes.
So if you have two nodes in your neural network,
you're doing deep learning already.
Then a little bit about the library
that we'll be using,
which is Brain.js.
And I'm sure you've heard of TensorFlow,
but there's a few reasons
that I chose Brain.js over TensorFlow.
First, it's a lot easier to use.
I'm not sure if you looked at their documentation,
but you have to learn a lot of new terminology
and a lot of new things
when you're using TensorFlow,
where with Brain.js,
if you know how to work with objects and arrays
it's really easy to get started.
Then with Brain,
you also don't need as much background
in machine learning.
As long as you have your data
and you know which algorithm you want to use,
you don't have to know about the math
or anything else behind it,
you have to know which methods to call.
And then the tutorials for Brain.js
are really straight to the point
and easy to follow.
So if you go through their tutorials
you'll find out you have a few,
really cool useful projects at the end.
And to get into a machine learning project,
there are few things you need to do
when you're choosing features
or those inputs for each of the nodes.
You have to ask,
what will add the most value for a user?
So that means,
is it something that's gonna make their experience better,
or is it something missing
that they've been asking for?
You just wanna make sure
that whatever features you choose
are going to lead to a prediction
that adds value for the user.
And then ask,
how do you get the information you need from a user?
Do you ask them for it?
Do you have them fill out surveys?
Do you data mine them,
while they're using their web browser?
How are you gonna get the information you need
to get those features?
And then this is a really important question
you should ask in the beginning:
What are you trying to predict
with all of the information you get from a user?
So that's the point
of the machine learning problem,
is you're trying to make a prediction
based on previous information.
And then one that we probably run into a lot
with just JavaScript and web apps in general,
is will the user actually care
if we make this kind of update.
That kind of goes back to
what adds the most value for a user
because even if it does add value,
if they don't care,
then you might want to consider if it's worth
all of the work and effort
to build this model to make predictions for that.
So make sure that any changes you make
or any predictions you're trying to make
are things that a user will care about
when you apply them.
Now we get to go back to the fun part
and do some more coding
and we'll add machine learning to this app.
So back in the HTML file,
I wanted show you
a property on one of these objects called cursor listen.
So whenever we find this box,
this function will get triggered.
So cursor listener basically just,
cause a function on the backend
to get a new predicted position
for all of the remaining objects.
And what's happening here,
is that it imports this user model
and when it gets called,
it goes to this backend API
and it sends back the users X, Y
and Z position,
how many steps they've taken
and whether they found an item or not.
And what that does for us
is on the backend,
we get to make our machine learning app.
So if you're familiar with node.js at all,
this is just an express app.
So we import all of our libraries and packages,
we set up an express app
and do some regular use stuff.
But down here,
is where we get into the machine learning.
So this is our initial training data.
And basically these are values
that we've gotten from users over time.
Like this is their current position right here,
and whether they found the item or not
which would be the box
and how many steps they've taken in the game so far.
So as you see,
this is just an array of objects
for our data,
that's all.
Then we have to have our initial training data output.
So based on these inputs,
we're trying to predict
how likely a person is to finish the game.
And, usually when they've taken more steps,
they haven't found an item
and they're really far away from the initial position.
They have a lower likelihood
of finishing the game,
which you can see with this array of objects.
So when we have our initial input data,
we have our initial output data.
So we put them together
into a single object
that we'll use in the Brain.js library.
So this training set
is just a combination of our input
and output arrays.
Now that we have all the training data
this is probably one of the best parts,
is building the model.
So with Brain.js is super easy to build a Neural Network.
This is it,
this is the one line of code
that it takes to make a Neural Network in practice.
And all this is,
it just has three hidden layers,
which is how you add a little bit more complexity
to some of the connections
that the Neural Network makes,
as it's trying to get a prediction
based off of the features you chose.
So we have our model here,
and then this is definitely the best part.
You get to train the model with the data that you have,
and all it takes is one method call.
So we've made the model up here
and you train it
just by calling the train method
and passing it the training data set,
that's all.
We have trained a neural network to make predictions
about whether a user will finish the game or not
based on how they've been moving around so far.
So all we've done here is,
when Brain.js runs the train method,
it collects statistics around
how many iterations it took to get the final value
and how the error rate decreases with those iterations.
And then we just do a quick run
to see if the model works,
that's all this is here.
So we trained it,
we got our statistics
on how well the model trained
and then we tested it.
So now we know that this model
is ready for user play.
So we've set up just a simple backend API
and all it does is get the data from the user,
which if you remember
that happens right here.
So we just get the position of the objects
and then we take the position of everything
and move it around
based on the likelihood
of a user to finish the game or not.
So if the user is more likely to finish the game,
we'll move the objects further away
to keep them playing longer.
And if they're less likely to finish the game,
we try to move the objects closer to them
so they'll find one
and keep playing and finish it.
Then at the very end of this call,
we just send the new position back
to the items that are still on the playing field
and they'll move around accordingly.
And that's all for the machine learning part.
So hopefully you see that machine learning
doesn't have to be really hard
or really complicated.
It just depends on what you're trying to do
and which libraries you need to use.
So now that you've seen the VR App in action
and you've seen how machine learning integration works,
there's a few other considerations.
First off, is the overall user experience.
Everything you design for a virtual reality world
should have the user experience in mind
because they're being submersed
in a completely different environment.
You don't want them to feel lost
or like they don't know what they're doing,
because then they'll abandon your app completely.
And another thing,
is that you want to make sure you're using data ethically,
especially when it comes to machine learning projects.
You don't want to take people's personal data
and do just unethical things with them,
like sell it
or use it to try to manipulate them
into buying things.
So make sure that all of the data you collect for users
is being used ethically.
And then this is a question
that comes up a lot in machine learning is,
what's the best algorithm.
Well, there really isn't a best algorithm overall.
It depends on your application.
So for example,
with this,
we were just trying to predict whether
a user will finish a game or not.
That could have been done with something like
a multivariate regression algorithm
or any number of other algorithms.
It's just what feels better for your data,
what gives you faster results
and what gives you the most accurate results.
Those are the metrics you should use
when you're trying to pick a machine learning algorithm.
And then as much as I love JavaScript and Brain.js,
when you get into the bigger machine learning problems
you'll definitely want to switch to Python,
just because they have a lot of different libraries
for things like natural language processing
and image processing
and just all of the bigger machine learning problems.
So if you want to do work with millions of data points,
Python is probably gonna handle it better
than JavaScript will.
And so, we wanna wrap up with some key takeaways.
It's really important
that you try to combine multiple areas of tech.
This is where you get to have fun
and be creative
and make new things
that nobody's ever seen before.
So don't be afraid to combine multiple areas of tech
that sound difficult,
because that might not be as hard as you think.
And then always,
always remember the ethics surrounding data
is so important that we keep our data secure
and that we make sure nobody's using it inappropriately
because I'm sure you've heard in the news
about data breaches
or people using personal information
to open credit cards or buy things.
So you really want to make sure
that all of your data is always secure
and being used ethically.
And of course just try new things.
It's okay if you don't understand it at first,
or if it doesn't make much sense,
but the point is to just try it.
With JavaScript we can do basically anything
from web apps to robots to machine learning.
So don't be afraid to take your skills
and just try new things.
And try to learn something
that you're interested in
and it solves a problem you have.
So with this VR game that I made,
I wanted a really easy game to play,
but not too easy.
So the machine learning really adds
that extra layer of complexity
that I was personally looking for.
And when you start to combine your interests
with some of your problems,
you get to make really,
really cool products.
And of course it's better
because everything is in JavaScript.
So this is all I have to share with you today.
I really, really hope that you liked it
and you learned something.
And if you have any questions
or you're interested in more of the things I'm doing,
remember to follow me on Twitter @Flippedcoding.
So thank you for your time.